I thought its own tab again I think I'm  going mad  sorry your father's gone at some point  we have to face up to who we are who  were meant to be I think I know where my  dad went that's right in the middle of  the devil sea it would be an adventure  death isn't an adventure  [Music]  what are you doing here Laura seven  years I've been on this island your  father they put me here now I see the  lightness intelligence so recklessness  what do you know about my father  [Music]  Laura there was more to my life than  boardrooms and business deals there's an  organization called Trinity it's looking  to start a global genocide you dad Jim  you had a bigger holiday got a knack for  the unexpected  you must stop the flora promise me  [Music]  ladies first open the two  put it down your finger that's pulling  this trigger you messed with the wrong  family  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]